horror is a genre that requires exact
timing and expert pacing in order to
deliver the maximum amount of scares
while every horror fan has a well
curated list of their favorite horror
movies there are lots of incredible
horror shorts you can watch for free
online short sweet and terrifying here
are some of the best spooky short films
the 10 steps children left alone by
their parents is common in horror but
it's effective for a reason parents
usually represent safety the 10 steps is
a perfect example of a short atmospheric
horror film with a grim punchline after
the power goes out while katie is
babysitting her younger brother her
father talks her through it over the
phone but by the end she ends up in a
very different place than she imagined
downstairs one of the best horror shorts
of the last few years
downstairs follows a security guard
investigating mysterious sounds in the
basement the film sticks to the basics
of horror movie rules and early warning
of things to come some light character
work to establish who is going to meet
the monsters and then just minute after
minute of Terror Scimitar Opia there
could be something a little unsettling
about perfect symmetry perhaps it's
because things tend to be naturally
chaotic and we expect disorder but for
whatever the reason Simba Tropea taps
into something very creepy for anyone
who's ever been creeped out by a Wes
Anderson movie Scimitar Opia leads you
to some very unusual places and shows
that the strange fear of perfectly
balanced things might not be so
irrational after all the facts in the
case of mr. hallow one of the most
inventive horror shorts and recent
memory the facts in the case of mr.
hallow continually plays on your
expectations and changes of perspective
the film shows an old photograph
depicting what seems at first like a
happy family vacation as the camera
dances around the photo details leap out
at the viewer and the final shot paints
a very different picture than the
opening scene three versus a strong
production design can often carry horror
movies with weaker strips but three
verse O's doesn't need the help the
script is surprisingly dense layering a
deeper
the ology and some hidden surprises into
a naturalistic dialogue three verses is
clearly indebted to classic black and
white horror films of the early 20th
century but with a multitude of visual
influences that distort the viewers
perspective about when the short takes
place
adding to the discomfort of watching it
alexia Argentinian film Alexia
acknowledges what we've always known
that Facebook is evil and trying to kill
us
well not quite the gradual buildup of
guilt and subtle implications of abuse
in a relationship help take this short
to the next level while the set design
and escalating discomfort keep it quite
scary don't move
before the opening title don't move if
it's already gotten all of its backstory
out of the way as six friends
accidentally summon a demon that's going
to kill five of them and let one live
the real treat of this short is the
incredible creature design and special
effects
don'tmove was supposedly created on a
low budget but you'll be hard-pressed to
notice as you watch it the birch it's
not hard to see the similarities between
don't move and the birch as they share
filmmakers both shorts have an
incredible creature design and a
stripped down story the birch follows a
bullied young boy given a mysterious
book and a promise from his grandmother
that someone will protect him sometimes
it's hard to see the forest for the
trees on stirs but let's just say when
the tree monsters look this good that's
not a bad thing this house has people in
it a series of unexplained edits from
home security footage is the set up of
the short film this house has people in
it which ends up being a surrealist
nightmare part of Adult Swim's
infomercials segments which air at 4
a.m. this short taps into a deeply
uncomfortable sense of voyeurism like
watching a reality show from a horrific
alternate reality where every day is
terrible lights out with the very simple
concept in execution lights out is about
a woman who sees a frightening figure
that appears whenever the lights turn on
like comedy horror can't depend on a
punchline that the viewer wasn't
expecting and this short is the perfect
example the smiling man most horror
movies hide the monster from view for as
long as possible to keep the viewer in
suspense
but the smiling man gives
you an upsettingly long direct look at
the monster the short focuses on a
little girl who follows a trail of
balloons into her kitchen where a
smiling man starts to play with her
which is obviously very very bad news
Skype mare in Skype mare a routine Skype
call between friends goes horribly wrong
when it looks like someone is moving in
the room behind one of them following in
the story tradition of Technology being
a delivery system for horror the film's
real villain is the shorts most
unexpected twist on my way Hollywood
loves the one take tracking shot but
we've never seen a tracking shot for a
horror short quite like the one and on
my way a man drives through town on his
way to a party while something strange
has happened to the residents of the
town if nothing else hopefully watching
this short will encourage you to
actually arrive at parties when you say
you well thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to